bonjour à tous je suis ben de la chaîne
nota bene et aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous présenter le second épisode d'une
série de programmes dédiés à la
propagande que j'ai réalisé avec l'ina
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
allez c'est parti pour un épisode sur la
propagande pendant la guerre d'algérie
dans sétif rendu au calme au travail à
la peine française dans sétif où se sont
effacées les princes des regrettables
incidents de l'an dernier le gouverneur
général yves chataigneau est venu
montrer que rien ne subsiste dans
l'esprit français de ce qui fut l'un
vers d'une journée les bords d'une
journée celle du 8 mai 1945
c'est le massacre de sétif un début de
mouvement insurrectionnel
indépendantiste réprimée dans le sang et
qui fera près d'une centaine de morts du
côté des français d'algérie et plusieurs
milliers de morts musulmans quand les
autorités tâche de rétablir le calme
l'armée française est mobilisé bien
entendu mais les habitants eux mêmes
ceux constitués en milice et participe
activement à ce massacre
tirant à vue sur les musulmans dans les
rues et les fermes alentour l'ordre
colonial est rétablie et les
métropolitains sont ravis de voir que
l'algérie est toujours un territoire
français où il fait bon vivre
il faudra d'autres massacres et d'autres
insurrections une décennie plus tard
pour que la situation commence à
inquiéter
en 1955 l'histoire se répète presque la
même une insurrection cette fois ci à ce
kid a fait près d'une centaine de morts
du côté des européens qui avaient
rebaptisé cette ville philippeville au
cercueil doit être saine les cercueils
de fils bill font un triste écho dans
une atmosphère tendue
le parrain du constantinois a intéressé
marc cette musique de requiem et ses
images de deuil fonds métropole leur
petit effet mais ce que l'on ne montrera
pas c'est qu'encore une fois la réponse
européenne et d'une brutalité
extraordinaire là encore les
représailles font des milliers de morts
tous les hommes adultes musulmans sont
abattues à vue par les habitants qui
sont armés et organisés par le maire
pour pacifier la région
il faut mobiliser le contingent et
renforcer la présence militaire
française sur tout le territoire
algérien
seulement l'armée française n'est pas
encore une armée de métier
on y voit les appeler puis les rappeler
les appeler sont les jeunes qui font
leur service militaire
les rappeler eux sont ceux qui l'ont
déjà effectué un an deux ans auparavant
et que l'armée mobilise de nouveau
ils ont déjà donné 18 mois de leur vie
sont rentrés on peut être un travail une
famille mais voilà on les appelle encore
déjà les vents forts arrivent a alger un
pont aérien va être établie qui
poursuivra sans discontinuité ce
transfert de force
il s'agit avant tout de maintenir
l'ordre sans lequel il n'y aura ni
réconciliation ni pacification
c'est la volonté affirmée du
gouvernement
nombreux sont ceux qui protestent qui
essaye d'échapper à cette réquisition
des corps nombreux sont ceux qui se
mutinent ou qui prennent le maquis il
bloque des trains et en sabots et
d'autre de la bretagne au centre de la
france mais on ne montre pas ça aux
actualités puisque les images à l'époque
sont encadrés par le pouvoir et donc
manifestement produites et montées pour
rassurer les appeler ce qu'une armée est
venu faire ici ce n'est pas la
reconquête comme une habile propagande
veulent faire croire
elle est venue pour assurer la
continuation de la vie algérienne et la
sauvegarde de groupes humains qui vivent
ensemble sur cette terre depuis sa
génération
à écouter ce reportage faire son service
militaire en algérie
c'est un peu comme passer un week end
chez les scouts qui durerait plusieurs
mois on y ait de la population on y
construit des routes et des écoles
l'armée cette fameuse armée qu'on dit
d'occuper à des représailles sans
scrupule à continuer les travaux
entrepris
on la voit jouant le rôle d'ingénieurs
et d'architectes diriger ou accomplir
les travaux qui ouvrent une route créer
un barrage de retenue
un déversoir
ou avoir quitté ses armes pour bâtir à
la place d'un assemblage de cahutes un
îlot d'habitations scène est commode
c'est à se demander si ceux qui
aujourd'hui défendent des aspects
positifs de la colonisation n'ont pas
été intoxiquée par la propagande de
l'époque comme l'ont été avant eux leurs
parents et l'armée continuent de
maintenir ce qui a été dans ce pays
un bulletin de santé que l'on connaisse
aucun des peuples orientaux qui
s'arrogent le droit de juger la france à
travers de drame algérien
comme il s'est fait architectes
ingénieurs infirmiers le soldat s'est
fait d'instituteurs dans les écoles
désertées il a pris la place du maître
victimes de la persécution
il a rouvert aux enfants les portes de
l'école on les a vus ces garçons
reprendre sous l'uniforme la classe
abandonné et dans ces pays où la
première forme de la civilisation
l'école était menacée de disparaître
l'école a pu se maintenir grâce à ces
farouches guerriers pour autant la
violence de ce qui est appelé le drame
algérien n'est pas épargné au spectateur
dans ce sujet de 1958
on y voit d'effrayant gros plans sur des
cadavres qu'il serait impossible de
diffuser tel quel maintenant et que l'on
va ici vous épargner mais l'idée de ces
plans et de mettre l'accent sur la
violence du fln les indépendantistes
algériens qui en effet enlève tu torture
et mutilent des européens
ces pratiques permettent aux pouvoirs
français de montrer dans les actualités
la sauvagerie de ce qu'ils appellent les
fellaghas en les appelant fellaghas que
l'on pourrait traduire par bandits de
grand chemin
le pouvoir français ni le caractère
politique de leurs revendications
il est désigné par leur violence et non
pas par leur combat
d'alger où l'appel impératif à la grève
générale de 8 jours lancée par le fln
avait trouvé un écho favorable
les forces du général massu chargés de
la sécurité ont dès le premier jour
lancé des sommations commerçants dans
ses ruelles où la rébellion a cru
trouver un asile impénétrables partout
où ces formations se sont montrées
inutile les parachutistes ont levé les
rideaux de fer est ouvert les magasins
fermés en laissant un garde à la porte
la violence de l'armée de pacification
est elle bien entendu invisibles ces
opérations d'ouverture de magasins
prélude à la bataille d'alger qui aura
lieu quelques mois plus tard sont en
réalité accompagné de rafles
d'exécutions sommaires de déportation
d'actes de torture et de barbarie en
tout genre on la prendra des décennies
plus tard que les appeler eux-mêmes
pratiqué la torture dans ces opérations
brutale qui avait en réalité deux
objectif démanteler les réseaux du fln
certes mais aussi terroriser les
populations civiles musulmane et tout ça
bien entendu n'est pas évoquée ici la
propagande ne s'arrête pas là les
conscrits ne sont pas les seuls qu'il
s'agit de convaincre du caractère juste
et utile de cette guerre sans nom
les français dans leur ensemble doivent
se sentir concernés
et voici comment les actualités s'y
prendront la france isolée de son
prolongement algérien son principal
client connaîtrait une crise grave
cette crise s'étendre est partout
déjà éprouvé par la perte du marché
indochinois l'industrie textile vers et
15 milliards de commandes annulées et
l'arrêt d'une partie de ces métiers
[Musique]
ce serait 5000 ouvriers sans emploi dans
le nord 7000 dans l'est 15 cents dans la
seule ville de roanne l'industrie
électronique en pleine expansion verrait
son élan brisé car l'algérie représente
7 milliards de francs d'achats
un savant mélange de raison d'état et de
raisons économiques qui ne manque pas
d'interpeller les capitalistes mais
aussi les travailleurs et travailleuses
de france
la disparition de l'algérie clé de voûte
de l'édifice africain entraînerait la
dislocation de l'union française
le standard de vie des français
n'échapperait pas aux conséquences de
cet effondrement
ce serait des jours de vacances en moins
ce serait des facilités en moins ce
serait des plaisirs en moins
être ou ne pas être une grande nation
telle est la question
la france mérite mieux que de se
résigner à la retraite
la mieux à faire que de vivre sur sa
grandeur passée de souvenirs et de
recettes gastronomie attention à demain
pensez-y
la guerre d'indépendance d'algérie a
fait près de 300000 morts du côté des
algériens et près de 10000
du côté des européens d'algérie et des
militaires français à la côte est cher
très cher au peuple algérien mais aussi
à la france et à son image sur la scène
internationale elle a précipité la chute
d'un empire colonial qui est de toute
façon auraient été emportés par ce
mouvement mondial de décolonisation qui
a touché tous les empires coloniaux
mais même après la guerre et la crise
pétrolière qui l'a suivi la france a
tenu son rang économiquement
si bien qu'aujourd'hui elle est la
cinquième puissance économique du monde
quand on prend du recul sur l'analyse de
ces images de propagande qui servent à
soutenir une idéologie ou à justifier
une action comme ça a été le cas pendant
la guerre d'algérie
eh bien on peut être tenté de remettre
en question le discours officiel et
finalement ça n'est peut-être pas un mal
car l'esprit critique et la vérification
des informations que l'on nous présente
est vital dans une société aussi
médiatisé que la nôtre ou une image de
propagande peut se glisser de façon
assez habile dans les programmes à la
télévision comme sur internet
évidemment c'est fini j'espère que cet
épisode vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous
laisser vos impressions en commentaire
et à vous abonner pour ne pas louper les
prochains programmes salut